In Islam, bro, you are known as an open
sinner. When you're doing evil in the
Sharia, your testimony is not valid. Let
me tell you why. Because you're coming
out and insulting your mom and dad. How
can you take your word seriously? Okay,
let me give you my number.
>> It got locked. It got locked. Uh, okay.
Now, I'm going to have to get you the
phone.
>> This is what I mean, right?
>> Sorry. Sorry. Get my number. I did that
on purpose.
>> I did on purpose.
Ladies and gentlemen from all around the
world, today is Sunday, July the 27th,
2025 and we gathered here in South of
Gaza Strip
to share our concerns about the ongoing
crisis in Gaza Strip. During the
humanitarian crisis that Gaza and his
people are undergoing
food in general and flour, bread
especially is becoming luxurious and
rare. It's not available for the
citizens. So our mission here to support
the citizens and to help their their
lives to be better by giving them these
trips. On behalf of those citizens and
those families, we thank what forever
for his wonderful support. It will be a
reason and making the people happy.
Thank you for being a reason in this
effort. [music]
[music]
Ever.
Hey, there he is. Asalamaikkum. How you
doing? You okay? Come. Come. Sit down.
Did you come by yourself?
>> Yeah. Yeah. What's up?
>> Come sit down.
>> I was just talking about you.
>> I can be on live. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. If you want to be live.
Yeah, that's fine. I don't mind.
>> One second.
>> This is YouTube.
>> Yeah. When YouTube Tik Tok the battery
died a bit. So, yeah. Do you want to Can
we Can we put his Do you mind put yours
on it?
>> It's better cuz then you don't keep
looking at it.
>> Sam, can you swap one of yours
>> or if you got extra one?
That's what we got. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You know, bro, instead of just
holding this uh Sam, you want this? Hold
it. Yeah. Cuz it looks more like an
interview, bro. I just want to hold Can
I just Can I Can I just tag it on
myself? Well,
>> actually, we won't be able to hear him.
Won't be able to hear him. That's fine.
That's fine. That's fine.
>> I'll hold it. I'll hold it. I'll hold
it. I'll hold it.
>> Yeah. Are we on? Yeah.
>> Okay. Talk to me.
>> Ali.
>> Yes.
>> I just feel like Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Advising your brother is one thing.
>> Yeah. Then
mentioning in a video my mom's own
voice.
>> Yeah.
>> Without talking to me first.
>> Is not a Muslim thing to do.
>> That's not a Muslim to do.
>> Okay. Let me put it like this. Firstly,
Aki, um, did you make that video public?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Now, anything that is public Yeah.
Okay. When you do a sin in public, for
example, you know, my situation that
happened um about a month or two months
ago about with that sister.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, there was a sister
who's coming out promoting divorce.
>> We're here to talk about me and you.
>> So, what I'm saying is that
>> Yeah, but one second. Let me give you
context cuz you asked me a question.
>> All I'm saying is like you multiplied
the sin by sharing it more and you got
you got a bigger fan base.
>> Let me tell you why.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> Okay. Let me tell you why that's why
when everyone debates me, they know I'm
right.
>> Okay. I'm not here to be I'm not here to
be right. You might be right. I might be
wrong. I might I might learn something
about just a simple conversation.
>> Yeah. Exactly. We're having a
conversation. I'm not here to be right.
I'm here to learn. So, what I'm saying
is this, bro. If somebody does a public
sin, yeah, and thousands of people watch
it. If I come and for example give you
advice and then for example, let's say
your video got let's say 100,000 views,
>> you can give advice without the without
the actual clip.
>> No, you can't.
>> No, let me tell you let me tell you why
not. Because when I when I
>> Why Why can you not?
>> I'll explain. You ask me a question.
>> I'll ask you ask me a question.
>> If I give you and for example, people
are going to say who's pilot. We don't
know who pilot is. Yeah. Okay. Number
one,
>> everyone knows who pilot is. I'm more
known than you.
>> I don't care. I'm not okay either, but
I'm just saying that.
>> No, that's fine. That's I'm not I'm not
here to be known. Like my my concern is
not how many people know me. I'm I'm not
really bothered about that. I don't
really care about that. That just comes
along with what I do. But what I'm
saying is this. When you do an open sin
publicly, bro, I have to or someone not
me. Somebody has to advise you publicly.
>> Somebody said they can't pay you much.
>> Sorry.
>> No. No. Come on. They say they can't pay
you.
>> That's his life.
>> That's his life, not our life. No,
that's that's maybe because of his
microphone.
>> Someone said he can't pay.
>> Then go to go to our I don't know. Go
>> to your life. Go to my live if you can't
hear me.
>> Excuse me.
>> YO,
>> no way.
>> Let's go.
>> How did you come here?
>> I was always here.
>> Where's gone?
>> Oh, no way.
>> You don't like him?
>> That's fine. That's fine.
He's just a bit
>> No, no, no, man. I know. That's fine.
I'm excited. I'm excited. I'm excited.
Yeah. So, so, so what we're saying is
that if we do a sin in public, we the
Sharia calls us to do it in to advise in
public. Obviously, IBM has a book on
this of how to go about it if the harms
outweigh the good. Yes. Okay. And
there's an etiquette to go about doing
that. Yeah. Okay.
>> I don't even follow the etiquette.
>> Okay. Good. So, so if you can correct,
I'm I'm happily correct.
>> Okay. So if I was you, I'd make a video
just with my face in it without the
actual clip, with my mom's voice in it
and the clip of me swearing out cuz
obviously I was under the influence. So
I regret that. I
>> That's good.
>> No, that's what I'm saying. But you're
sharing it to your fan base which is
multiplying the sin. So I don't think
that really counts anymore
>> when you say that you cuz you would have
just advised me without mentioning.
>> So what I'm saying is this, bro. From
what I know, you're perpetually doing
things against your family, your mom,
your dad, your sister, other sisters
walking on the street. So you're not
you're not one second. Let me spin up
because I heard you hear me out. You're
doing something perpetually. You're not
So for example, if you done it
>> No, no, no. We're talking about we're
talking Okay, let me be honest.
>> Let me let me let me finish my point.
>> The elites here, let me finish my point.
>> I don't think you got to that level.
>> Okay. I'm not I'm not that level. I
don't want to be on that level.
>> I went to jail for 4 weeks.
>> Yeah. Just because like I might get
arrested, but it was a certain guy from
a certain religion. I was making certain
remarks and um it's like now now they're
arresting me every day. So you don't
like how it's like uh you don't know how
it's like living under that pressure.
>> True.
>> And um you know only thing I'm thinking
about is oh I hope I don't go jail
today.
>> Okay look that's
>> Do you know what I'm saying? And then
what is happening is in my family right
my dad my mom my sister they've all
called police on me and they keep
calling police on me.
>> Okay but why?
>> Sorry.
>> But why?
>> No reason.
>> Habibi.
>> Habibi. No reason. No reason. Watch my
life.
>> Okay. Pilot. Pilot. Pilot. Your your
sins are public. That's why I mentioned
it.
>> No.
>> Okay. Okay. One. Since I came out of
jail. Okay. One second. One second.
Pilot. Have are you known to record a
sister walking down the road and you
say, "I want an ara."
>> Okay. But what does a mean?
>> I don't know.
>> It means respect.
>> So, one sec. Let me get this right. So,
say sister's walking down the road.
Okay. Let me put it like this. If I was
to do that about your sister, would you
say, "Yeah, Ali, fine." Or would you
come looking for me?
>> You want to respect my sister?
>> No, no, no, no, no. You can't talk about
my sister.
>> No, no, no, no, no. I don't want to.
Your sister is my sister. I know. Your
sister's my sister. I have I have
respect and honor for her. I'm saying
>> loyalty to me. So she
>> No, no, no. She she should have loyalty
to
>> she should she No, no, no, no, no. But
but do you see? Okay. Do you see what
just happened?
>> Okay, good. But do you see just what
happened, bro? When you do that to
another person's sister,
>> you don't like it. And right this like
we don't like it.
>> What if I told you I know that yo,
>> bro? Bro, it's irrelevant.
>> She was 19 years,
>> bro. Bro, it's irrelevant.
>> She wasn't in this school uniform. She
was in work clothes.
>> Okay. I don't care if she
>> about young sister. I don't care if she
was a 25 year old. It's not about her
age. The moment your sister and by the
way your sister got in and contact me
from Instagram. She's my sister. May
Allah bless and preserve. Why? So you
replied.
>> Yes. Yes. I replied.
>> I know you're a married man.
>> Yes.
>> So is that haram?
>> No.
>> How?
>> I'll tell you how. I'll tell you how.
I'll tell you how. How? I'll tell you
how. I'll tell you how. I'll tell you
how. Okay. You ask me how. Okay. Good.
Let me explain. You asked me. Let me
explain. Okay. Good. When it comes to
free mixing, you need to question what
free mixing is. For example, can I speak
to a sister here? Yes. It's not free
mixing. Can I? Let me tell you how I
work with sisters in my team who are
dealing with the salah head of salah
instructors. I speak to them on the
phone. For example, hello sister. Okay.
Two sisters accepted Islam today. Have
they they contacted you? No, brother
Ali. They haven't contacted me. Okay.
Let me know if they contacted you.
>> When you were having conversation with
my sister working paid for it,
>> I don't get paid when I used your own
theory against you.
>> Okay. So, so let me explain in the in
the Sharia me talking to another woman
who's not m your sister or anyone is
married
>> and I'm a married man and if she was and
by the way there are
>> you ask your wife before I don't need to
ask my wife
>> and let me let this my wife doesn't even
need to ask me if she is for example
>> you want to talk about control of woman
>> okay
>> habibi I don't I don't I'm not here to
control woman
>> no I know you push that that's why I
read you sometimes
>> no no I don't control when do I push
control I don't push control listen
habibi if look my wife can speak to a
another man if it's pertaining to
arguments. Say for example, let's
suppose she's applied to another man.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> No. No. That's not Islam, bro. That's
that's that's not Islam. We don't lock.
You're going to lock your wife in a
cage. Habibi. That's not Islam. That's
not Islam. And that's not how you should
treat your wife. You're all obsessed
about me. Maybe
something else.
>> Habib, that's not how you should treat
in Islam. You're
>> allowing your wife to match.
>> Brother, you look Yes, I did. But let me
finish by sentence. If you keep stopping
me, I can't talk. My wife or any woman
or me, we are allowed to speak to the
opposite gender for a reason. For
example, can I go and speak to a woman
and say, "Yeah, how you doing?" You're
right. Yeah. What you doing today? Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Do you want to do you want to
meet up? Why? I just got That's haram.
>> No, you can't if you're done with us,
>> habibi. I'm not talking about Can I
speak to Can I speak Can I speak to any
What I'm saying is for example, there
are sisters who are married who are in
our team that I speak to. You want to
say sister for example arguably say what
argument say my sister's not no no no no
no no in my team
>> she's what
>> she's in my team
>> habibi the team we should all be in is
Allah and his messenger team I'm not in
nobody's team I'm in the team of Allah
and his messenger and I have okay good
>> that's why I don't like either
>> yeah I don't care about bro forget him
let's not swear don't swear okay listen
to me habibi firstly let's clarify your
sister may Allah bless her she cares
about you she got in contact and I said
to her sister can you arrange that I can
even if he means come to your house like
brothers and talk Okay. But on the
contrary,
>> yes,
>> why did she call police and while I'm
getting arrested behind the police,
she's out?
>> Good. Good. One second. One sec. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. One
second. One second. Doesn't make sense.
>> That's wrong. If if she's done that, if
she's done that, however, I don't know.
You have taken your life.
>> I know my whole story.
>> Okay. Okay. But I'm here to hear your
story. But firstly, let's put things in
context. When you go and record a sister
and say, "I want to when you come and
say, "Oh, I can't wait for my dad to die
so I can do this." When you come and
tell insult your mom and said, "F your
tears." When you come and do stuff like
this, bro, to us Islamically,
>> I could disprove all of them.
>> Okay, good. That's why. Good, good,
good. But in Islam, bro, you are known
as an open sinner.
>> Therefore, good, good, good. Allah,
good, good, good. So, that means, bro,
you can be better than me in the sight
of Allah. I'm not here to make you feel
bad. I'm a nobody. I commit sins. You
don't know.
>> Good. So, listen to me. What I'm saying
is, bro, listen. When you
>> huh?
>> I mean, like, you actually got burners.
What's burnness?
>> Oh, sorry.
>> What's burnness?
>> Okay, good. So, I'm saying I commit
sins, you commit sins. Yeah,
>> you're doing it publicly. I might be
doing it in in private. The point in the
Sharia is this. If I commit a sin in
private and someone exposes, that's
haram. When you go out in public, bro,
and disrespect your mom and dad,
>> good difference is what? Remember the
issue that you didn't know with the
sister? Yeah. She comes out and publicly
calls her an evil and I and I reminded
her and warned her against her in
public. Okay. Now, that even came at the
cost of my family's pictures being
leaked. Alhamdulillah, no problem. Now,
what I'm saying is this, bro, your mom
and your dad. Look, bro, you can commit
sins on the road. Swear this that.
>> Let me just leave the last point.
>> Good. So, so I'm ask a question. Let's
start with Let's start with the R thing.
>> Why did you record the sister and say I
want I'm going to
>> If you think of the bigger picture, if
you look at the bigger picture, it's my
comedy where I said R. I didn't say the
word because you can't even say on
TikTok when you get banned. I
>> Why you recording? I said respect. Okay.
I have to record for my safety. Please
don't.
>> Habibi, would you like if I recorded one
of your female members, my family member
members?
>> Yeah. No, bro.
>> Okay. But that's why Hold on.
>> What you don't like?
>> No. Hold on. Hold on. That's why I got
beat up for it and I knew nothing
>> because I accept that mistake.
>> Good. But that was a long time ago.
>> Did you repent for that?
>> Well, that's between me and Allah.
>> Alhamdulillah. Let's move on from that.
>> That's it. Why you ask?
>> No. No. No. No. No. Good. So, one of the
one of the conditions of a repentance is
you hate the sin, you repent. You've
done repentance. Alhamdulillah, you're
not going to do that again. Correct.
>> Of course, I'm not going to do that
again. No, but this this it's not like
you made me realize that. I realized it
for myself.
>> Good. Even baby, I'm a nobody, bro. You
might remind me
>> like an hour.
>> I'm good, good, good. I don't know that.
That's news to me. So,
>> what were you doing at 22?
>> 23, bro. I just became a Muslim. But
when I was 16, I was doing madness.
>> You just became a Muslim. What were you
>> at? Bro, I had no religion. I believed
in God. I had no religion. And let me
tell you something, bro. Bro, bro, I
used to make my mom's life hell. Look,
let me tell you something. My mom used
to cry. Yeah. I used to
my dad. But we don't want to talk.
>> But your mom also came out and said what
you said is not true. That he you beat
her.
>> She's going to have more loyalty to her
husband than me. Of course.
>> Okay. We don't know what
>> I know though. I know. But I know behind
the pilot. Pilot. Okay. Good. But to us,
bro, when you're doing evil in the
Sharia, your testimony is not valid. Let
me tell you why. Because you're coming
out and insulting your mom and dad. How
can we take your word seriously?
>> But you are known as a fic, an open
sinner.
>> No.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Habibi. That's why.
>> To be honest, I know what you're not
going to like this one,
>> but they call you manafic.
>> Yeah, that's why I be called I be called
the spy Christian monafic misogynist.
Okay.
>> You record girls as well? What's Okay.
Me recording girls.
>> No, no, no, no. Give one example.
>> Like that girl that was screaming at you
when you were just like,
>> "Bro, she was there was 10 cameras in
front of her.
[laughter and clears throat]
>> She agreed to it,
>> bro. There was 10 cameras and and you
know what? Let me tell you something.
She knew it. And guess what? She came to
me and said, "Can you take it down? And
I took all the videos down. You know
why? Because I didn't want to tell her
butt. But no, no, but she knew. No, I
took it everywhere down. But she knew
it's being recorded. She wanted to be
recorded. Yeah. So now what I'm saying
is this, bro. Why are you insulting me
down like that on camera willingly?
>> Well, she knew the cameras were there
and she You know what? You know what she
said to me? You know, she said to me,
she know I don't know. She said to me, I
want to talk to you. I thought she was
going to talk to me pleasantly. When the
cameras went on, she went mental. It's
as if she was planning.
>> Okay, pilot. Pilot, that's fine. Pilot,
why are you insulting your mom and dad
both? All right, guys. Because they just
put me through so much pain. Honestly,
>> you can't.
>> Even if you ask, I hear you. I know bro,
you know why I'm telling you for two
reasons. Number one, it's a major sin.
Number two, I'm telling you, Allah will
destroy you. Parents, when it comes to
your parents, bro,
>> I didn't respond to your video. I know
that was true. Like, there's some things
out of my control where like this could
fall on me and I'll die. I know this cuz
I
slowly day by day, I'm repairing the
relationship. God, that's between me and
Allah. So, you you came a bit too late
now. I'm not trying to say I just I just
want to get this on the record. That's
it.
>> That's fine. I've come late, but my my
job is 100%. Look, I'm I'm happy if you
are taking steps. Even if it's baby
steps,
>> that's that's fine. If if the battery
dies, they can go and watch it on my
channel or somewhere else. You can take
you can take it if you want.
>> I say like Allah is between me and
Allah.
>> Yeah.
You know by by the way people people
that are watching I just want to say
like
>> guys you need to understand also it's
very important that if there are people
egging you on yeah
>> if they are like for example bro let me
tell you something you are getting
>> they're useless
>> you're getting the same sin for example
bro if I if I insult someone's mom and
they insult my mom back I get the sin
for causing them to insult my mom. If
there's anyone that's watching this and
>> No, no, no, no, no. But
>> they do it. I do.
>> No, I know. I know. But I'm talking
about the mute.
>> No, I know. I know. But habibi, forget
somebody else's mom. You You're saying
things about your own mom, which is not
right.
>> This is different. When I'm angry and
stuff like that,
>> there's no excuse, bro. Let me just say
your mom got a stick. Yeah. So, this
guy,
>> what happened? Forget him.
>> Don't worry. Don't worry. Sit down. Sit
down.
>> Sit down.
No. Who Who are they?
>> No. Sit down. H. Sit down. Sit down. Sit
down. Sit down. Sit down.
>> H. Look.
>> Even if your Look, look. Even if your
mom beat you, which you shouldn't. Yeah.
>> Your mom. Your mom. Your mom or your
dad, bro. You can't insult your mom. You
can't insult your dad, bro. Cuz my thing
is this, bro. There's other people
coming and doing the same thing, trying
to get lives or views. So, what you're
doing is, well, you're making this
normal and it's not normal. Bro,
>> I only accepted my mistake. I said I'm
not.
>> Okay. Are those videos up?
>> What videos?
>> The videos of you.
>> No. No. No. No. Is it up on your
channel?
>> No. On my channel.
>> Okay. One second. Is it Is [laughter] it
Have you taken down on your channel?
>> There was It was never on my channel.
>> So, what was it? Was it alive?
>> It's the Clippers. It's the Clippers.
>> So, it's alive.
>> Oh, you're not streaming it. That's the
point.
>> No, no, no.
>> So, like when the reason I'm going up
people clip me. It's never my account.
All I post is like just me like in
Dubai, me and Turkey.
>> Okay. So, you go live, people clip it.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Good.
>> I can't live. It's just my life.
>> Okay. What's What's your real name? Like
your first name?
>> Ome. Is that what you want to be
remembered for?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, when you die, you're going to
be remembered for insulting his mom and
his dad died and recording people.
>> I'm only 23. I got a lot more to do.
Trust me.
>> How do you know you're not going to die
tomorrow?
>> If I if I do,
>> okay, if you die tomorrow, bro, do you
think all these people are going to
remember you?
>> Do you know one thing is um have you
studied stoicism?
>> I'm a full sto
I don't care in the sight of Allah. H
listen
>> in this in the in front of Allah. No one
cares about your stoism.
>> I have a different relationship with
Allah.
>> Bro, we all have
>> my dad. He
>> doesn't need to. Allah says the
relationship
>> Allah might favor me more than you. You
don't
>> exactly. Did I say did I say otherwise?
Bro, your relationship with Allah tells
you to not be disobedient to your mom
and dad.
>> I already accepted that.
>> Good. But but but listen, you I said to
you, if you die tomorrow, would you want
to be remembered for that? You go, yeah.
>> No, I don't. I don't.
>> Okay, good. So, what I'm saying is this,
bro. All of those people that are
watching you. Okay, I did ask you. You
did say yes. So, it was a
misunderstanding. You didn't mean that.
Listen to me, bro. For all the people
that are watching you, when you die
tomorrow, bro, none of them are going to
remember you.
>> And even if they remember you, you know
what they're going to remember you for?
Oh, P used to do this, this, and this,
this.
>> I just need um I just need you to tell
me one thing I don't know.
>> Okay, good, brother. If you know that,
this makes even worse because you
already know, habibi, why are you doing
it?
>> Why am I doing it? Why didn't I just
answer that? Like,
>> no, you didn't,
>> bro. Like, I was angry cuz they kept
calling police on me. But why do they
call him? Okay. No, because like does my
mom which country you from?
>> I'm Kurdish. From Turkey.
>> You're Kurdish? Okay. So basically I'm
from Pakistan, right? Okay. Very like
stick together country. Yeah. Loyalty
and stuff. You know what I mean? So it's
like it's like when you call police
outsiders for far to your own house to
arrest your son.
>> It's like
>> where I'm from
>> that is unacceptable.
>> But to me it means that what you're
doing is so unacceptable. They have to
do something unacceptable.
>> I don't do anything.
>> Habibi. Why would your mom and dad call
police on you for no reason?
>> That's what I'm trying to say. No one
understands. They just like
>> So, let me get this right. You're
sitting at home,
>> mind your own business,
>> you ready for this?
>> Imagine I don't think you you've been
through this or anyone's been through
this. Imagine your parents being your
biggest test. Imagine that. How it go
make anyone go crazy. So,
>> okay. No matter what your test is, you
for example in your household, okay, I
don't believe your mom and dad are just
going to say, you know what, just
sitting down and do nothing. Let's put
the police on. No way. You know why?
Because let me tell you something. Let
me tell you something. No, no, no. Okay.
If it's for content,
>> you know it's for content.
>> Call it. No, it's not.
>> But I I rate you. So, it's not for
content. How you doing for content? How
you doing for content?
>> Sorry.
>> How do you know it's for content?
>> You're repeating the same points over
and over again. Why did you do it,
>> bro? Bro, you repented.
>> You said to me, "No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. I you you said my family
called police on me for no reason."
>> Sometimes. Yes.
>> Did I repeat that same question? No. I
said, "Why would they call police on you
for no reason?"
>> No. But sometimes there's no reason.
Sometimes I ask my sister for a charger.
This is all on live by the way. And she
starts screaming. I'm asking her a
simple request and she didn't say no.
She didn't say she starts screaming. And
then my dad then calls the police. So
it's like I don't even have a chance to
defend myself and police already at my
house because I'm already wanted from
all the stuff I did when I was 15. And
it was like bro it's all catching
[music] up to me basically because I I
don't think you're really from the
roads. I don't think you understand.
>> I'm not from the roads. I don't want to
be from the roads. With those respect I
don't I don't want to be from the roads.
>> I don't want it either. That's why I
came out.
>> Okay. Good. Good. So what I'm saying is
bro why Okay. Can you not do something
positive with your platform? You have a
platform.
>> Yeah, I know. But I just came out of
jail last week.
>> So, let me at least like put my feet
down.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Set up.
>> Okay. I'm saying I can I can help you if
you're willing to and you don't need my
help. I'm saying as a brother, I can
help you to find if it's if it's for
example a specific job, whatever it is,
I can help you, bro. But the thing is
Allah says,
>> "Look, look, you can't get a job. We've
got from the records out here. We're not
no sleep to no 9 to5. Okay.
>> We're not making
>> money. What's wrong with 9 to5?
>> We're not making money for someone else
while we get 1230 an hour. We all
>> I used I used to do Uber. There's
nothing wrong with it. I used to do
Uber. I used to Uber for like 34 years.
>> I used to work in Tesco's.
>> Tesco. That's dead.
>> I don't I don't care, bro. Habib is
halan money. I don't care.
>> Look at everything.
>> What's wrong with
>> I think is everything has more money
than you.
>> Huh?
>> I think is everything that Tik Tok
influencer he got he went controversial
for saying that. Oh. Um.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I've done a video about him.
Yeah. He was he was he was criticizing
the Tesco.
>> He was in the right.
>> Yes. No, he wasn't. No, he wasn't. Bro,
if let me tell something in in the sight
of what's respecting myself is serving
the dean of Allah. What's not going to
be like bro? Good. Good. Good. Exactly.
I only get one life.
>> Exactly. Good. Good. Let me tell you
something. You only get one life. Why?
>> Forget your parents. Why do you No. Why
do you serve Allah?
>> Okay. Can you serve Allah by working at
Tesco?
>> Can I serve Allah by working at Tesco?
>> Yeah. If your priority is the hereafter.
>> No. Cuz Tesco is Zionist.
>> Habibi.
>> Habib.
>> Yo. Go. Okay. Okay. Okay. Give me uh
give me give me give me Audi. It's going
to get worse.
>> You trying to get banned, bro, when I
start talking about Palestine.
>> I don't care, bro. Bro, I've done videos
in Palestine, bro. I I've done more
videos. I've got to find IDF soldiers,
bro. Please. You think I care about this
word? What if I worked in Audi?
>> Huh?
>> Audi? Would you work in Audi?
>> What? No, I would have worked.
>> Good. You know what the problem is, bro?
This is what I'm saying to you, bro. The
fact that you look down on the 9 to5.
You know why? You're chasing a dream.
Yes. And there's nothing wrong with it,
by the way. Look, don't get twisted. I'm
not saying to you, if you said to me,
bro, I want to be an entrepreneur. I
would. Yeah, that's good. But bro,
everyone, you know that millionaire,
you're looking at the end product. He
all of them started at 9 to5.
>> Everyone at 95.
>> All of them went through the same [__]
I'm going through.
>> Good. Okay. So, what I'm saying is this.
Then, why do you have an issue with 9
to5? Go speak to any entrepreneur who's
a millionaire. Tell you, you know what,
bro? I used to clean people's shoes.
>> Good. So, what I'm saying is, bro, your
priority is in the dunya. When I tell
you about Tesco and Ali, you're like,
"Bro, I don't want to do that." Why?
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. It was accident. It
was I did on purpose.
>> No, I did.
Why would I do that on purpose?
>> I don't know. Like, maybe you're just
getting a bit fresh.
Why would I get pressed for what? Cuz
>> you are repeating the same promise.
>> We're talking about Audi and we're
talking about Tesco. I
>> wouldn't work at Audi.
>> Okay, good. But I'm saying that is a
problem. Not that you're not working at
Audi. The perception you have in their
head that working a 9 to5 getting a
minimum wage. All right. Look, let's
just take it out.
>> Anyone can do what they want. Good.
>> In my life, in pilot's life,
>> like I wanted to be a footballer. I
played for Brenford under 12. They
released me cuz I'm Asian. There's no
Pakistani ballers in the Prem for a
reason. Then I want to be a boxer and I
actually did become a boxer for once and
then you know the money and all that got
to me and then like I've had so many up
and downs. It's like
>> you don't really know the half of it. So
it's like okay why am I taking advice
from okay
>> and I wouldn't look I've gone through
ups and downs as well with respect.
Everyone go ups and downs. There is no
excuse to go and commit sins on your
parents
>> bro. It's like sometimes I have to go
live here for my own safety bro to show
the police that I didn't do anything.
like you know that's how deep it is
saying it's on public and it's like I
have to be like
>> okay you can go live if you got safety
issues but the the the thing I'm saying
is this
>> the thing I'm saying is this bro look I
you know this place you see here you see
this strip here yeah I used to come in
and party in here every week
>> every week that's not this much
>> it's not this much it's not I'm not
proud of it I'm not proud of it
>> so why I'll tell you why you see this
>> no let me tell you why because it's to
learn a lesson I used to come clubbing
partying here and I'll give you a
specific location. There was a penthouse
out there. Let me tell you something.
Yeah. I used to come here like an idiot
up and down. Let me tell you something.
You know why? Cuz that's all I knew. I
would watch rap videos. I watch people
who are famous. I watch them. I would
want the girls. I want the partying. I
want the holidays. I want the money. And
let me tell you something. I was not
happy.
>> Is that what it is? You see someone
else?
>> I never said that, bro. I'm not I'm not
trying to I'm I'm No, I'm not. You can
maybe relate. What I'm saying is this,
bro. It didn't
>> your mom like why you not like backing
me? You know how it gets. Baby, if I had
issue with my mom, I'm telling you, I
was I used to be like you.
>> I never got angry at your mom ever,
>> bro. For we get angry, bro. I used to I
used to say things to my mom I hate to
myself.
>> But but I
and I can't say to you. I understand
that,
>> bro. I didn't believe in Allah and his
messenger. Bro, I was not a Muslim. I
would do dumb stuff. You are a Muslim.
You know better. Aki, I was not told. Do
you get what I'm trying to say? So, what
I'm saying is this, bro. When I would
come here, it would not bring me
happiness. So, the life you're changing,
when I talk about Audi, there's a reason
I'm mentioning Audi and Tesco. I'm not
talking for the sake of it. If you chase
the dunya, bro, let me tell you
something. You're never going to get the
>> Let me tell you something, bro. I chase
the
>> Good. So the
>> Good. Let me tell you something. Now,
Khabib, he admitted the field that he's
in is haram.
>> Good. So him doing that fight and the
money is not himself.
>> So it's all haram.
>> Yeah, it's haram. The the income that he
earned is haram.
>> Simple as that. But I don't care if it's
>> bro. all the for example if he said
sponsorships are not from gambling
places and it's from let's say Red Bull.
>> Okay, good. No. Okay, good. But at least
he intermiss and says you know what I
don't encourage you to do this and it's
not permissible.
>> If I was in his position and I was as
strong as that
>> I I would do the same thing you do
>> which is what
>> which is just fight get my money to save
my family and stuff and then repent
later on.
>> Okay. But but you see the calculations
you're doing is and it's a good thing.
It's a good thing but what I'm saying is
bro it's not going to bring you
happiness. You can get the duna after.
The prophetam said when you're making
dua ask for Allah give me the best in
this life and the hereafter. There's
nothing wrong with the dunya. But if you
carry the dunya in your heart, you'll be
destroyed. If you carry the duny in your
hand, bro, Allah will help you. The
point is this, bro. Do you think I don't
like the duny? Bro, do you think I don't
like driving nice cars? Do you think I
don't like driving wearing nice clothes?
Bro, of course I do.
>> What's your point?
>> The point is this, bro. I'm saying when
I mention 9 to5 to you, like, no, no,
no, no. It shows that
>> that's my point. You are so fixated that
you believe
>> you're going to give away a whole life.
One life you have 9 to 5 waking up 7:00
a.m. No sleep work your way up. Work
your way up.
>> No, I already have.
>> Good. Work your way up. Bro, if you want
to be a businessman, let me tell you
something, bro. If I If you want to be a
businessman, you start off with a 9 to5,
bro. Everyone does. And then you know
what you do? You save the piece, you buy
yourself a van, and you go and sell
whatever it is, bro. You work your way
up.
>> My vans, bro. I want to have yards, bro.
>> Okay, brother. Brother, have yards.
Okay. Why? Why? Why? What girl?
>> I'm going to have on my yacht. Come in
my
>> What's What What's girl scale? Are you
talking about wives? Are you talking
about? What are you talking about?
>> Just talking about four wives. All of
them.
>> Four. Yeah. Four wives. No problem. I
have four wives. No problem. Allah's
give you that going to see. It's just me
and my wife. Alhamdulillah. Are you
>> telling me I'm not going to be happy?
>> No.
>> L.
>> Yes. Good. Let me tell you something. If
you think if you think Let me tell you
something. If you think the woman the
yacht, bro, let me tell you something.
I'm okay. Thank you very much. Yeah.
Okay. If it's if it's halal, we can if
you if you fix up, we'll join together
and we have like
>> that. Okay. Listen, brother. What I'm
saying is this year, you can attain
that, but if you put your happiness in
there, you're never going to be happy.
>> All right, fine.
>> Mark my words. You know what you're
going to do? You're going to you know
that you know those you know those
nothing's going on. Okay, I'm here.
Speak to me.
>> No, is there a problem?
>> Why would I talk to you? Okay. Okay. Why
is it Why would he have a problem with
you? Everyone's watching you. No one
looking at me,
>> bro. No one's looking at you.
>> Pilot.
>> Pilot. Genuinely, do you want to change
for the better?
>> Yes, bro. And I'm doing
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Habibi. I I'm saying
I'm saying Listen, listen to me.
>> That's That's my Okay. Boom.
>> Wait, wait, wait. One second.
>> Why? What happened?
>> Are you gone?
>> Really?
>> Are you finished?
>> No, no, I'm fine. Am I finished?
>> Huh?
>> What? What do you mean am I finished?
Like prove me wrong.
>> He said, "Are you finished?"
>> I didn't say you're finished, bro. He
said, "Are you finished?" What are you
saying? He said he said, "Is the life
finished?"
>> Sit down. Sit down.
>> You're going.
>> Why would the police come? Why would
police come?
>> Okay, I'm not No, I understand. But what
I'm saying is, bro,
>> listen. What I'm saying is, bro, listen.
Well, I am willing to help you genuinely
if you want, bro. Listen to me. Listen
to me.
>> How are you going to help me? Give me
another listen listen bro. Y are not
going to make you happy.
>> No, but I just need to get away from my
family.
>> Okay, listen, bro. Okay, let me ask you
a question. I respect how how old are
you?
>> 23.
>> Okay, you're 23. Okay, bro. I will ask
you a question. Then why don't you move
out your house if you're a girl getting
with your mom and dad? Yeah. You know
what that would happen? Let me tell you
something. They keep my address.
>> Bro, let me tell you something. Yeah.
Well, lie. Let me tell you something for
an application.
>> Okay. Okay, bro. Let me say something.
At least at least if you know you don't
get on with your mom and dad. Okay.
Don't be in the And you talking about
stoism. Yeah, bro. Get your own place.
>> Yeah.
>> At least I got bailed to this address.
So, I'm tied down to this address.
That's why you don't.
>> Bro, you can get your own place.
>> I can't right now cuz my sentencing is
like
>> Okay. Okay. Listen. Okay. Listen,
listen. Okay. Listen. If Okay. Okay.
Listen. If I help you get your own
place.
>> Oh, it has to be after January. That's
when my
>> Okay, that's fine. No problem. I'm
saying happy. Listen. If you're I'm as
your brother. Look, I I hate the fact
that certain stuff that you've done
publicly, okay? And it's wrong. You're
seeing you admit it. No problem. That's
a sign of repentance, the fact that you
hate it. But bro, listen to me. If you
want to change, I can help you. But if
you're here, bro, let me say something.
If you're here to waste my time and say,
you know what? Oh, yeah. I'm here for
>> you see me on live. No, I'll be calm
now. Trust me.
>> Okay, good. Good. What I'm saying is
this, bro. Please, when it comes to your
mom and dad, if they say something you
don't like, go out and walk.
>> Walk where they lock the doors, bro.
>> Bro, come on, man. Come on.
>> 23y old man who's been doing boxing,
they lock doors on. You don't know what
pop. You're a 24y old man who's in
boxing.
>> My pops gang member mob. Trust me. Locks
all the door has be locked up.
>> Okay. Okay. But is he afraid that you're
going to go and do some madness?
>> Possibly.
>> So, so there's a reason he's locking the
doors.
>> What if I'm not going to do it? What if
I want some food?
>> Okay. Okay. Good. If you tell your dad,
"Dad, if I'm going to stay here, I'm
going to say something I might regret.
Can you let me go?" You think your dad's
going to lock the door? No, he's not.
>> No,
>> bro. Have some. Look. Well, let me tell
you something. Allah says in the Quran,
we do not change
>> forget that. Go on, man. Look, look, we
do not have we do not change the
condition of man until you change within
yourself. Bro, if you do the same things
and want different results, you're never
going to change more than words, right?
>> Good. So, what I'm saying is Allah does
not change the condition of man until he
changes what's within himself. If you
want to change
>> me to change with
>> good and you are good. I'm giving Allah
says remind the benefits of believer. If
you want to Okay, good. If you know, I'm
saying to you, bro, you can take my
number. I can talk to you and I can look
you don't need me. I'm a nobody. I might
benefit from you. What I'm saying is
this. Yeah. My Okay, let me give you my
number. It got locked. It got locked.
It's okay. I mean, I'll read the whole
thing. Uh, okay.
>> Now, I'm going to have to get you a
phone.
>> This is what I mean, man. Sorry. Sorry.
Get my number.
>> I did that on purpose.
>> I did it on purpose.
>> So, he didn't.
>> May Allah destroy me if I did that on
purpose, bro.
>> Yeah. Okay. If you want, bro, I I'll if
you if you for the sake of Allah, if you
genuinely think, why would I drop him?
>> Okay. You hold it, please. You hold it.
Please. Just hold it.
>> Yes. I'll do it. Please, bro.
Please assume the best, bro. Why would I
drop your phone on purpose, bro? No
cover or nothing.
>> No. Okay. Okay. If it's damaged, I'll
I'll repair it and I'll get a phone
shot. Okay. Okay. Why would I do it on
purpose, bro? Okay. I don't know what
kind of people you're dealing with.
>> I'm just paranoid, man. All right, man.
>> No. Okay. Okay. But listen, bro, it was
nice talking to you. Please, bro. Please
allow the lies. Your mom and dad, bro,
I'm telling you, Allah will destroy you
if you your mom and dad. Look, you can
come and you can cuss out next man on
the road. Yeah, which is still haram.
But, bro, don't do that, bro. Even if
it's your mom and dad, okay? And as your
brother, I'm there if you need when it
comes to finding a place, finding a job,
fixing your ways, bro. As your brother,
I'm here if you want to work with me. My
job is to give you a reminder, bro. I've
given you a reminder. I've learned for
you, learned from you. You told me some
things that you clarified.
Alhamdulillah. Okay. So, it's nice
talking to you. May Allah bless you.
Preserve in. Okay. Have you Have you
prayed?
>> We can pray together.
>> Wait, wait, wait.
>> Get coffee.
>> I'll get you coffee.
>> No. No. Come on. I need some time.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Take time for
yourself.
>> Yeah. I got
>> We can pray is together.
>> Wait, what time?
>> Here. Look, look. Now, what time is it?
It's 9:00.
>> Coffee shop.
>> What time is it?
>> Let's pray together.
>> Yeah. Come. Come. Let's go. Okay. Get
coffee. I'm under.
>> Come on. Let's go. Coffee shop. You
still need to pray. Habib W. You still
need to pray. No. No. That's from a huge
decision.
>> That's from No, I can't force you. Even
if you're under pray, pilot, you still
need to pray. I'm saying I'll pray. I'll
pray when I'm a bit more sober.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. But in
prayer,
let's get coffee shop. Come. Come this
way. His
chairs are gone. Okay,
>> it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's
fine.
>> You're a legend. You know why?
>> I like that of you.
>> Why not? Please, man. I'm telling you,
bro.
>> Nothing I said was li
something. Yeah, bro. You know, I was I
was not a Muslim. I came to Islam. Yeah.
Tell you something. One thing I'll tell
you. One thing I told you, I tell you
something. Yeah. Before I used to chase
the money, the girls, the party, all
this kind of stuff. Yeah. It is. It is.
And I'm getting
>> 100%. It's very hard. But let me tell
you something.
If you give that up for the sake of
Allah, Allah will give you all of that
inal way.
I'm telling you. You know why? I look I
put it to the test myself. When I came
to Islam, let me tell you something. The
money, bro. No. Let me tell something.
Let me I'll give you this as a
beneficial reminder. I will never see
it.
>> When I first came to Islam, bro, my dad
kicked me out my house. Let's go copy.
>> My dad, one second, one second. One
second. My dad kicked me out my house.
You know why? Because I sayahill my dad
stopped me from praying salah bro I
couldn't pray salah in my house bro I
used to tiptoe to do woo my dad kicked
me out for three months I lived at my
friend's house yeah I used to work at
Tesco's okay 9 to5 getting paid £89 an
hour yeah and we used to go da on do da
on the streets yeah bro let me tell you
something you know right now I have
everything a man could ever wish for
if I'm saying this to show off may Allah
destroy me if I'm to show off you know
why I'm saying this to tell you bro
Allah will give you the and the but you
have to make that sacrifice. If you
don't make that sacrifice, you wouldn't.
Right now, you're here, you got the you
got the likes, all this kind of stuff.
Yeah. But let me tell you something. If
you sacrifice all of that, bro, w Allah
will make you use your platform for
good. You do halal, bro. Allah will give
you everything he wants. Two, three,
four, Allah will give you good
bro. He would make that sacrifice.
>> One thing though, yes.
>> I don't think you're reading in the
church and that I didn't read in the
church. When I read
>> Oh, you did. All I'm saying could you
tell him last hour I went to speaker's
corner and debated like
>> brother today on the live you said
something that made me think that bro
the potential you got you know when you
talk about the prophetam he was they
tried to bewitch him.
>> Yes. Okay. What did you say that you
said we don't worship him?
>> Yeah we don't worship
>> brother. Let me say something. I've
never heard anything from the dah say
that cuz obviously you worship Allah
alone.
>> Good. So that shows your potential bro.
Why don't you use that brain for good?
>> So obviously don't you know like I
already know like
>> no but that's what I'm saying. You're
clever and you're smart bro. Use it for
the good
>> brother. You should I tell you
something, bro. Your potential is
immense. Be a pilot. D. Okay, listen to
me. Listen, listen to me, bro. Listen.
You're a pilot, but the the plane is
going to the wrong direction. That's why
I came to join you as a co-pilot to turn
you back around. Okay. Okay. May Allah
bless you. Please make dua. I'm going to
make dua for you. Okay. Wall change for
the sake of Allah. May Allah bless you.
Okay. Okay. Not for me. Follow.
>> Okay. If you if you guys uh if you guys
need to come pray, if you need to pray,
we're here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Anyways, guys, alhamdulillah.
I would join brothers and sisters. Like
I said, I don't know where the thing I
would drop this on my mind, brother. I
can't force anybody. I just want to give
my heart to heart. I know how it is. I
know the temptations. I know, brother.
I've been here. I've done it. I know
this kind of stuff. Subhan Allah. But
guys, the main thing is what? That we
give advice. My job is to give advice.
Inshallah, if he change, he change. If
he doesn't, bro, we can make dua, you
know. And it reminds me of Shakani, you
know, Shakan. Subhan Allah. He used to
drive a car that was automatic. When he
moved to Saudi, no, no, he used to drive
a car that was manual. It's uh in um I
think in Syria when he was studying,
when he went to Saudi, they gave him an
automatic car. And you know what he was
doing in the uh in the car? He was keep
looking for the clutch. And every time
he was looking for the clutch, he was
keep pressing the brake. So he would
have a sudden stop. And he said, "Subhan
Allah, look how long it's taking me to
get used to from manual to automatic."
And when we give Nia to someone, we want
immediate changes. It doesn't work like
that, bro. The reminder today, a
reminder tomorrow, and you don't know
this man might be better than all of us
together. We don't ever look down on
people. We don't ever judge people. When
we're talking about judgment, we judge
from what's apparent. For example, if I
see a brother who's drinking alcohol,
I'm not going to say only God can judge
him. But I don't follow Tupac. I'll say
this brother's committing an open sin
drinking alcohol. But I'm not allowed to
say, "Ah, this guy, he probably commits
zena. Oh, this guy, he probably does
robbery." That is judging. However, if
we see, for example, a sister committed
sin, we judge Allah, which is what?
She's committing a sin. For example, um
dressing up inappropriately. But we
cannot come and say, "Oh, this sister,
she probably sleeps around." You cannot
say that. That's the two things people
don't understand when it comes to
judging. We judge from what's apparent
like said we used to judge based on sto
but you cannot accuse someone and say oh
this brother wears earring oh he
probably goes and robs people what are
you talking about the earring is haram
but you can't come and add insert things
in there. So may Allah subh guide our
brother pil in our job is to reminded
and there's nothing else we can do. May
Allah guide him and make it easy for him
inshallah. So, let's get back into the
DA.